I've been waiting for this because of
course I've been talking to the FBI for
six years now I gave them a lot of the
documentation that really opened it up
when they in the IRS arrested the
American Chuck blazer whom usually
became a cooperating witness we didn't
fancy jail time then they got Jack
Warner's son Darren and the two more
witnesses I think I know they are but
yeah I mean there's a lot of the
speculation today from people who didn't
even know it was happening and I think
what we've got to notice is this has to
be the end for Sepp Blatter an extremely
dubious FIFA and the world cup in 2818
may will be in England who taken out of
Russia and have you taken out a cation
probably in America this is what the
reality is that I've been looking at for
years well a lot of predictions their
first of all if we could talk about
President Blatter as he's known as
you've heard the authorities are saying
they're not at this stage investigating
him so why will this lead to his
downfall in your view well there have
been investigating and I don't who's
saying that they're not but they have
been I know I've given the FBI
documentation is very interesting about
platter what is corrected he's not been
arrested or charged today what is also
to be borne in mind is he sat in the
middle of the room are always trucks
were around him imagine David Cameron's
having his cabinet meeting suddenly the
fraud squad bursted adorned hall after
cabinet out does that leave Mr Cameron
untouched some blemished of course not
he either knew and he has to go he
didn't know and he certainly has to go